what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk about things marvel and
mcu and this is going to be my falcon
and the winter soldier episode
1 breakdown before we get started let me
know what you thought about this episode
rank it 1 through 10 10 being the
highest in the comments down below
obvious spoiler warning for the first
episode of the falcon and the winter
soldier i'm about to break the whole
thing down and we're going to start by
talking about that ending
scene the new captain america now as was
explained in this episode
sam gave up the shield and the mantle of
captain america
rhodey even asked him why he didn't take
up the mantle
sam explained that he thought the mantle
belonged to steve rogers
it was more than a shield it was more
than the mantle it was about the person
behind it and that was his best friend
steve rogers
and sam thought nobody including himself
should take on that mantle of captain
america but it should die with steve
so he gave the shield up and he gave it
to the smithsonian but at that
end scene the government went and picked
a new captain america and this
is us agent john walker now john walker
is straight from the comics in fact even
in the comics after steve rogers is done
as captain america john walker becomes
the next captain america instead of sam
now in the comics nick fury did suggest
sam wilson as the next captain america
but they decided to not go with him
because they weren't sure
if the people were ready for a black
captain america
so in the comics when steve rogers gets
too old to be captain america
john walker becomes captain america now
john walker
is part of the u.s military so it's
already somebody that did
exist within the u.s government he was a
soldier much like steve rogers was
and if you notice he got a new uniform
this is nothing like our original steve
rogers captain america uniform
he even has a different star logo which
is also an
a for america and this is fairly similar
to the star that john walker wore on his
uniform as captain america in the comics
it's even in the same place
now in the comics john walker does have
superhuman strength and stamina just
like steve rogers
however his ethics and morals aren't
exactly
like steve's he's much more brutal than
steve rogers was
he definitely does not care as much as
steve and i think we're going to see
that happen
in the falcon and the winter soldier
john walker becoming
kind of brutal so the government has
elected their own
captain america most likely one that
they can control
and that brings us into a theory that i
have about who the flag smashers
actually are when we're introduced to
the flag smashers in switzerland
we learned that their leader is insanely
strong we have also
seen and heard that they are extremely
strong in some of the trailers as well
and in the ending scene where sam is
talking to torres sam starts to get
really concerned about
how strong the leader of the flag
smashers was and taurus says
you don't think he could be a and then
sam cuts him off and we don't hear what
he was going to say but i believe he was
going to say
a super soldier it looks like these
people have superhuman strength and this
is
a series about captain america a new
captain america but captain america
nonetheless
who had the super soldier serum however
we do know that the serum got into the
wrong hands people tried to recreate it
this resulted in the hulk but it also
resulted in people like the winter
soldier
super assassins so i believe that some
members of the flag smashers including
their leader
have volunteered for some type of
experiment for a super soldier serum
they're a terrorist
organization terrorizing the world and
they seemingly have superhuman strength
the leader took down torres like he was
nothing and as we've seen from some of
the trailers
some of them beat up bucky pretty good
and he himself
is a super soldier so you can't keep up
with the super soldier unless you are
indeed yourself one and i think we're
going to see that revealed in future
episodes
now we'll get started with the scene by
scene breakdown easter eggs and
everything you need to know
in the first scene we see sam getting
dressed he's ironing his clothes he's
putting his suit on
and on his bed sits the shield and as we
know he's getting ready to go to the
smithsonian where he's
actually going to donate the shield to
the museum and obviously this is a very
hard moment for him captain america
gave him that shield at the end of
avengers in-game sam was supposed to be
the next captain america but sam feels
like
that title should only belong to steve
rogers because you have to remember
steve rogers was captain america to sam
as well
falcon looked up to him and he looked up
to what captain america meant
and it's a really weird and hard thing
to try and take your hero's spot which
is why he doesn't end up taking
on the mantle and he donates the shield
and as he contemplates this
whether he should be giving the shield
up or whether he should be taken on the
mantle
we can see him put the shield in the
same exact bag that steve gave him the
shield
in if you take a look at that scene in
avengers in-game this is the exact same
back
and as he does this we can actually hear
the conversation take place in his head
steve rogers says
how does it feel and falcon says feels
like it's somebody else's and that's
because again he views captain america
as his captain america he doesn't think
of himself
as captain america but of course steve
says it isn't
because sam is supposed to be the new
captain america now from here we
actually jump
back in time nothing too big probably
under a week but we cut to a scene where
sam's doing his
job working for the air force again now
sam was on the run with captain america
after civil war
and so was bucky but as we hear the
therapist tell bucky
he's been pardoned so both of them have
actually been pardoned because sam is
working with the air force again
and of course their pardon they help
save the world of course they're not
going to hold anything that happened in
civil war against them so sam is in a
plane being briefed on what his mission
is
he's told there's a criminal
organization called laf
and they have targeted captain vasant
he's not really told much
about laf besides the fact that they're
high-powered but he is told that captain
buzan's airplane has already entered
into nation airspace where the us
air force is not allowed to go so sam's
mission is to go get
captain vasant but not be seen it's a
covert mission
he also has troops on the ground led by
first lieutenant torres to help him out
with his mission from here we get a look
at sam's
new suit which we go on to find out that
it's actually a stark tech suit
he's got a nice new hud display where he
gets information transferred right to it
and he even has thermal vision with it
and he has an
upgraded red wing which is his combat
drone we saw red wing in captain america
civil war we then saw red wing again
in avengers infinity war where sam had
it jump out and split into three
different drones that attacked thanos
army
red wings got a new paint job and seems
to be a much more upgraded model
now sam soon learns that laf has already
hijacked the plane
and captain of assad so he uses red wing
to cut open a door with its laser
he bursts in and we get some awesome
action sequences
and if you notice the way he fights is
an awful lot like steve rogers as
captain america and if you listen
closely when his thrusters go off they
sound a lot like iron man's repulsor
blasts
again stark technology sounds like stark
technology and i love how tony is still
in this they still make us think about
him even though he's gone but falcon
definitely has some moves of his own
with his upgraded armor
using his wings as shields of course
using the jet pack on the back to rush
into people and of course using his
wings to take him into flight to hit
people even harder now when sam
eventually does talk to captain vasat
if you notice on his right arm what we
see on the left side is a sword logo
sword which we saw show up in juan
division what stands for sentient weapon
observation and response division
basically the new shield
is a good organization now of course
hayward was bad but he was arrested for
that and the falcon in the winter
soldier takes place several months after
the events of avengers in-game so the
events of one division are before what
happens in the falcon and the winter
soldier so hopefully sword at this point
is being ran by
a good person and hopefully this show at
some point in time
will show us if that's true perhaps nick
fury is running it now we did see him at
the sword base at the end of spider-man
far from home which takes place around
the same time that the falcon in the
winter soldier takes place
so it is possible that nick fury is
running sword at this point in time we
then have some action sequences that
clearly show that falcon is superior
in the air even against heavily armed
helicopters with missiles
him in red wing show some new abilities
like sam's grappler
his sticky bomb launcher and red wing
fire some missiles and has a turret
we also see a little bit more of his
stark tech with his suit as his jet in
the back gets shot
but it fixes itself so clearly his stark
suit has some type of ai
in it and thanks to tony stark's
technology and the suit
sam manages to save captain vassant
before getting to the border we then go
to tanisha with sam and torres and sam
is fixing his red wing and this is
actually the scene where torres tells us
that
sam's technology and suit is indeed
stark tech
here sam also says that he's been
working for the air force for six months
now
which means that the falcon in the
winter soldier takes place roughly
six months after avengers end game then
a civilian recognizes sam and calls him
an avenger
he says you brought my wife back to me
which means that his wife was actually
snapped the avengers of course brought
everybody back and it's clear that the
world
recognizes that they were responsible
for saving everybody and falcon is
recognized as being an avenger we then
learn about the villains of the show the
flag smashers and they're putting secret
codes and signs all throughout different
cities of the world
we learned that they like chaos and that
they liked it better during the snap
because they want a unified world
without borders
and that's basically how it is in the
comics in the comics flag smasher is an
actual person
but it does start a group and a movement
wanting people to get rid of their
identity so they could all be one
so instead of having flax masher be an
actual person it's an organization
and here's where we first start hearing
questions about steve rogers
and it looks like nobody really knows
what has happened to him and it's not
really ever answered in the episode and
this is totally intentional on marvel's
part there's conspiracies about steve
rogers being on the moon
and probably other pretty crazy
conspiracies and at one point in time
they say that captain america is gone
but this doesn't tell us if he died it
doesn't tell us if he went back to his
own timeline
he could very much still be alive it's
only been six months since we last saw
him and yes he was old but he wasn't
about to die
and i think marvel's leaving this pretty
vague because he could show up at some
point in time perhaps in the finale
we'll have to wait and see but then we
go
to where sam is giving the shield to the
smithsonian and here we see
roadie a cameo that we knew was coming
but we didn't know when it was coming
but this cameo makes a lot of sense if
you consider roadie's rank in the air
force plus you consider the fact that he
was an avenger but sam talks about
needing new heroes for the new
time that they're in this is going to
lead in the new avengers eventually and
they could possibly introduce some new
characters by the end of this show that
could be in the new avengers
from here sam talks a little bit more
about why he didn't take up the shield
he says that the shield is a great
symbol of hope but it's really about the
person behind it and nobody could ever
replace captain america which is why he
doesn't accept the shield
from here james and rody take a walk and
they go down a section of the
smithsonian dedicated to captain america
in this section is the history of
captain america
as you can see they have some of his old
suits and they even have his old army
uniform
as sam and roadie walk through the
display we can actually see that there's
a section dedicated on the history of
the friendship between steve and bucky
who we have yet to see in the episode
one of the columns says bucky barnes
friend and brother killed in action with
a question mark after
then says him and steve rogers grew up
together and were lifelong best friends
it talks about how they joined the
military together and then in 1944 while
they were on their mission to thwart a
hydra weapon transport in the alps bucky
barnes was thrown from a train
presumed dead but then came back in 2014
70 years later where it was revealed
that hydra found him and turned him into
the winter soldier it then goes on to
the next column that says winter soldier
from
friend to foe on the top it talks about
the events of captain america the winter
soldier and then on the bottom it talks
about the events of civil war
one of the line's reading steve's
loyalty to his old friend talking about
bucky coupled with his refusal to sign
the sokovia accords
led to the dissolution of the avengers
and drove the captain into hiding with
other like-minded avengers including
natasha romanov
wanda maximoff and sam wilson the other
columns say a threat from within hydra
and there's a copy of the sokovia chords
and what they stated on the far right
that says a team
divided so this shows us that america
knows and the world knows
everything that happened with captain
america steve rogers
bucky and sam we then go through more
captain america memorabilia including a
newspaper from captain america the first
avenger that is titled us bombers hit
hydra factories
we then see some gear that he wore his
motorcycle and his first captain america
shield
and on display we can actually see the
very first
captain america comic book published in
real life
this is captain america comics issue
number one
written in 1941 written and penciled by
joe simon and jack kirby the cover is of
captain america in world war
ii punching hitler also on the cover is
bucky it says also
captain america's young ally bucky so a
super awesome easter egg of a real comic
that they actually put in the mcu as we
go through the memorial we see more
columns one states out of hiding new
york under attack
talking about the events of avengers
infinity war we see one that says the
blip and then we see one that says the
vanished
stating all the people who were vanished
and then of course we see
all of the captain america propaganda
which he was originally used for in
captain america the first avenger so
even though cap is no longer with us we
can definitely feel
him in this episode they eventually walk
to the shield that sam just gave up that
is now on display next to captain
america suit from the first avenger
one of his first suits next to his last
shield we then learned from rhodey that
the world really isn't okay after the
snap
the world doesn't really trust each
other anymore people who used to be
friends aren't friends anymore countries
aren't getting along with other
countries and this is why in this series
groups like the flax smashers are
arising
rohde says that he'll be in touch with
sam which leads me to believe that we
are going to see him
again within this series we then move on
to bucky barnes
the first thing that we get to see of
bucky in the falcon in the winter
soldier is of his past
bucky is having a nightmare reliving an
assassination job that he had working
for hydra we see him take out a whole
squad in the hotel
give us a hail hydra he then kills a man
to leave no witnesses who we later find
out
is the son of mr nagajima his new friend
and we'll get to him in just a bit
because we know why
bucky decided to befriend him we learned
that bucky is in therapy but he's not
going by his
own choice the government is actually
making him go
after being one of the avengers and a
hero and saving the world on avengers in
game the government decided to pardon
him they're going to drop
all of the charges for all of the bad
things that he did in the past
including the sokovia accords with
captain america and sam
however part of that pardon deal is that
he goes to therapy
and this is so they make sure that the
winter soldier programming in him
isn't causing him to go out and kill a
bunch of people and after bickering back
and forth with the therapist who remains
unnamed in this episode we find out that
bucky is making amends of some of his
wrongs from the past
and he has three rules that he has to
follow when making amends rule number
one is that bucky can't do anything
illegal which he technically did
he took control over somebody's car and
he assaulted somebody which is breaking
rule number two which is you can't hurt
anybody
and rule number three when making amends
is telling them that he is no longer the
winter soldier now this congresswoman
was going to have another congressman
killed and there was an assassin in the
car with her
who pulled a gun on bucky so really it
was self-defense but he kind of lied
about how everything went down
however the end result was a dirty
congresswoman got thrown in jail
presumably now bucky finally comes to a
realization and therapy
and this is thanks to the doctor who we
find out was actually a soldier herself
saw a lot of dead bodies so knows what
he's going through he's been fighting
his whole life except for the wakanda
name drop that happens here when bucky
was in wakanda he actually had peace
there was a calm
but it didn't last he had to fight yet
again but now he actually has a period
where he doesn't have to fight so right
now bucky's focus is finding out
what he wants discovering who he is and
that's what's going to be explored
throughout the series
now there is a license plate that they
zoom in on in one of the scenes it's a
new york license plate that has the
numbers 10872
fq and the only thing i could really
find on this that kind of matches up
with these numbers
is warlock issue number one that came
out in august or the eighth month
of 1972. so it could be a little easter
egg referencing adam warlock coming in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or it
could mean nothing we then go to bucky
and his new friend mr nakajima the two
of them go out to eat and mr nakajima
gets bucky a date
however he does show bucky a newspaper
that has the obituaries on it and he
shows bucky a person who has died at a
very young age
and this combined with seeing the red
bean mochi reminds him of his son
and he tells bucky the story of how his
son was killed he said his son was
working overseas and the cop said that
he was in the wrong place at the wrong
time but he felt in his heart that it
was something else
and of course by the end of the episode
we learned that it was actually bucky or
i should say the winter soldier who
killed his son and this is actually why
bucky is hanging out with mr nagajima
he's trying to make amends with mr
nakajima for what he did he murdered his
son as the winter soldier now of course
he was brainwashed and it wasn't really
him but it still
was him and that's really hard for
somebody to understand especially
if it's their son now he never tells him
in this episode even though he has the
intention and he bails on his date to
specifically go and
admit this to him but he doesn't admit
it however of course by the series end
he will eventually tell him
what he did and we'll see if he forgives
him or not we then follow sam to new
orleans where sam is visiting his family
specifically his sister and her boys we
see him show up to the family business
that his parents left him
and his sister we see the sign that says
wilson family
seafood falcon gets out of his truck and
is greeted by his two nephews who call
him uncle sam and then his sister
jokingly calls him uncle sam as well and
salutes him this is because the nickname
for the united states
is uncle sam and he was supposed to be
the new captain america
of the united states we see the wilson's
family boat which is named
paul and darlene now paul and darlene
are of course sam's parents
both of which have passed away in the
comics both of them were actually
murdered not at the same time
but separate times his father paul was
actually a minister who had been killed
while trying to stop a fight between two
rival gangs
his mother was then later on killed by a
mugger when she tried to protect her
children
now we're not sure if this is the case
in the mcu
as in the comics sam's father was
murdered when he was 9 years old and the
way that he talks to his sister about
what they decided to do
right before their father died makes me
believe that they were both adults so
his story could be different in the mcu
but i'm sure we'll figure that out as we
get more episodes the boat behind their
boat is named
hermann now there is a herman schultz in
the marvel universe who goes by
another name the shocker and he already
exists in the mcu
we have seen him in spider-man
homecoming however i do doubt that this
is an easter egg reference to hermann
schultz slash the shocker but it's more
along the line of just the name of the
boat in the background
now sam's family is in a pretty tight
situation we go on to find that even
though falcon
was dusted his sister and her kids were
not and now that everybody is coming
back from being snapped the business is
kind of going under and she needs to
sell the boat
sam doesn't want to of course because
it's his family business and the house
is also connected to it so they could
lose the house
sam is trying to come up with solutions
to fix the problems but his sister has
already moved on and is set on selling
the boat
but sam being the hero that he is
convinces her to let him help
then we go back to bucky on his date and
this is an extremely
important scene bucky brings his date
flowers he's extremely old school
because well the last time he went on a
date was about 70 years ago
then eventually she asked how old he is
and he says 106. he says it very
seriously but of course she takes it as
a joke
now she probably doesn't realize who he
is when he was the winter soldier and
had a lot of publicity going on about
him he had very long hair and in the
scene he's not showing his arm in fact
she asked why are you wearing a glove
and he said
that he had poor circulation so he
clearly doesn't want people to know
who he is or what he used to be now she
eventually goes on to talk about yuri
she talks about how hard it is for him
since his son died and the hardest part
for him is not knowing how he died
now this sends bucky a little bit over
the edge because he is the one who
killed yori's son he feels so guilty
that he can't take it anymore he just
leaves his day
and goes to yori's home when yori opens
the door we can see a little shrine
dedicated to his son with a picture of
him on it and it is
indeed the same guy from bucky's opening
scene who couldn't put the key in the
door hole to go to his room who bucky
ended up killing now as i've said
at some point in time in the series
bucky will tell yori that he is the one
responsible for the murder of his son
whether he forgives him or not we'll
have to see meanwhile in switzerland we
learn more about the flag smashers and
there are some really important things
you have to know
torres who in the beginning was working
with sam is there to investigate the
group because as he stated in the
beginning the group works online
they work through secret forums and
messages and we find out that
a bunch of civilians are there for some
type of event that the flagsmasters are
going to do
they all get face masks which has the
flax smasher logo on them which is the
hand
now all of these civilians are there
because they somewhat believe in what
the flax masters are due and what
they're really there for
is to be a distraction so this is a
dangerous terrorist group using
normal people to help do their bidding
now again they communicate through
secret messages
and just as torrez puts on his mask he
receives a message that says
ren which i'm sure you figured out means
run and right as everybody starts racing
one of the flag smashers leaders throws
two bags out the window of a bank
most likely money but at this point we
don't really know but that person then
jumps
off the second floor possibly even
higher lands on the ground like it's
nothing
barely even flinches when landing on the
ground this person then shows us that
they are
extremely strong and they almost kill
torres
now we know by some of the trailers that
they've shown us for the falcon and the
winter soldier that a lot of the flax
mashers are insanely strong
and as i mentioned in the beginning of
this video it's most likely due to the
fact that they've had some type of super
soldier serum injected into them
that's the best explanation of how these
people could be so strong they're pretty
much like captain america they're doing
all these things that steve rogers could
do who of course had the serum and this
makes the flag smashers
very very dangerous meanwhile sam and
his sister are trying to get a loan so
they can keep their family's business
this is where the banker actually knew
who falcon was
kind of he had to give him some hints
but he realizes that he's an avenger and
immediately starts to geek out
and you think that would mean it's a
very good thing for sam and his sister
but unfortunately as we see it does not
work out for them
this is where we get more of a feel of
what it was like during those five years
where everybody was
blipped and the consequences of what's
happening as everybody is coming back
he says sam can't show any proof of
income for the past five years and
that's because sam was
dusted and sam wants to apply for a
specific type of loan that used to be a
thing
however they say that that's changed
that's had to change because of all the
people returning from being snapped
all these people returning to a very
very different world a world where a lot
of them
probably don't have jobs this would
result in a lot of people taking out
loans which would result in the banks
changing a lot of things which is what
happened but the banker asks a very
important question that a lot of people
have been wondering how exactly do
superheroes make money he even asks if
tony stark was the one who paid them and
tony stark did fund a lot of things for
the avengers the avengers headquarters
all of their sleeping quarters
weapons and probably had some type of a
budget for food and stuff like that but
as falcon explains
you mostly rely on people's good will
meaning that you'll essentially get
things for free or a discount because
you're a hero trying to save the world
they don't get the loan but sam tells
his sister that they're not going to
sell their family's boat or their house
as they're walking back to their truck
we see sam's license plate says
184 eje which could be referring to
captain america volume 1
number 184 which is titled captain
america and
the falcon sam gets a message from
torres which says he needs to talk asap
so sam gets to a secure line and then
taurus shows him what happened in
switzerland they talk about how crazy
strong the leader of the flagsmasters
was and how he was in the dark
right after it happened he vanished so
he was a super strong person who was
clearly trained
now this part right here is extremely
important sam looks very concerned and
taurus says
you don't think he could be a and then
sam cuts him
off because what he was most likely
going to say is you don't think he's
a super soldier remember this series is
still kind of about captain america
sam was supposed to be the next cap and
cap had a super soldier serum injected
into him and we know that hydra and
other people were experimenting with the
serum as well
and making super soldiers that's how
bucky became the winter soldier
and that's most likely how sam and bucky
team up to see if the flag smashers are
indeed super soldiers now the final
scene as i talked about in the beginning
is the government going behind sam's
back and electing a new captain america
this is u.s agent john walker and he has
the shield that sam
gave up to the smithsonian he gave it to
the government so nobody else could have
it
but they gave it to john walker along
with the title of captain america and
this obviously is super emotional for
sam
and that's where it ends but we do know
that at some point in time
sam is going to get that shield back
because we've seen him train with it
in many different trailers but that is
it for the falcon and the wonder soldier
episode
1 be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest theories and
other breakdowns on episodes to come
in the meantime rate this episode down
below 1 through 10 10 being the highest
what did you think about it and do you
have any theories of your own
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and you can always follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you